نادراً ما يتحدث بوتين عن أفراد عائلته ،
أعني أنه يكره تمامًا القيام
بذلك ، لكنه فعل مرة واحدة في مقابلة ، هل
هذه المقابلة الودية للغاية التي
أجراها مع أوليفر ستون
أم وربما لأنها كانت
بيئة ودية في مقابلة ودية
عندما كان الموضوع  جاء بوتين في الواقع
قال شيئًا هنا هو التبادل
، هل أنت جد ومع ذلك ،
كيف تحب
أحفادك الإنجليزي الفردي نعم ، هل أنت
جد جيد هل تلعب معهم
في الحديقة
نعم أنا فخور بهم
حسنًا رونالد أم أنت  أعرف هذا فقط من
الواضح أنه لا يريد
التحدث حتى مع أوليفر ستون ، لكنه
جعله يقول
إنه لديه أطفال ولديه أحفاد
ونادرًا ما يلعب معهم
، وهؤلاء هم الأطفال الذين
نعرفهم عن بوتين.  وأطفالهم ،
هناك أشياء أخرى
لا نعرفها بشكل صحيح ، لماذا يوجد الكثير من
الغموض حول رونالد ،
نعم ، كنت سأقول إنه كان
سيبدو أكثر سعادة إذا كنت خاضعًا
للإيداع  نعم أه حسنًا ، أنت تعلم
أنه صور نفسه أه على
أنه القيصر الروسي المثالي ، أعني أن
هذا يتعلق برجل من
الغموض الدولي والقوة إذا كان بإمكاني أن
أقتبس ما تعلمه ، اقتباس
أه أوستن ، أعني فكرة
شخصية يحبها السياسيون الغربيون  الشخصية
ثم نراها طوال الوقت وترىها طوال الوقت على الهواء
ونراها جميعًا في الإعلان التجاري
حيث يتم ذكر أفراد العائلة ، فهذه
ليست طريقة عمل هؤلاء الأشخاص ، هذا الأمر
يتعلق بشخص ما على وجه الخصوص أنا
يعني أن هذا يتعلق بإسقاط لعائلة قوية
مثيرة للاهتمام ، لكنه يعترف بذلك ، لكن
هذا ليس ما يريده ،
فلن تكون العائلة
حول تمثاله عندما يريد
هذا التمثال في المربع الأحمر ، حسنًا ،
آه إنه  ملحق
له إنه مجرد شيء
تريد إبعاده عن الطريقة التي تقر فيها
بأنك رجل عائلة جيد ولكنه
مهتم أكثر بالظهور أه مع
الكنيسة الأرثوذكسية الروسية أو في
المواقف العسكرية أو التخلص منها  إن اه أنك تعرف أه
عاري الصدر على ظهر حصان
لإبراز قوته ، هذه
العائلة القوية من نواح كثيرة ، هو ضعف
الفيديو الجديد الذي دخلناه للتو
قبل أن أتحدث معك في الجزء العلوي من
الساعة ، إنه عن الخنادق التي كانت  حفرت من قبل
القوات الروسية وحفروا تلك
الخنادق في الغابة الأكثر
تلوثًا إشعاعيًا
حول تشيرنوبيل والتي تسمى الغابة الحمراء
التي أتوا إليها ، نرى
آثارًا من
خنادق دباباتهم التي حفروها
في هذه المنطقة والتي كان من الممكن أن
تسبب لك معرفة من  يعرف ما
حدث لهؤلاء الجنود لا نعرف أه
ما عانوه أه
نتيجة فعل هذا
كيف تعتقد أن هذا كان يمكن أن
يحدث
جيدًا أنت تعرف مأساة تشيرنوبيل
شيء يدركه الأوكرانيون جدًا.
عندما عانى الأوكرانيون أكثر ليس
فقط الأوكرانيين ولكن في الغالب الأوكرانيين
كانت واحدة من جرائم النظام السوفياتي
الذي سبق هذا
النظام الروسي الذي نتعامل معه بشكل
صحيح.  الآن حيث
لم تحدث الكارثة في
تشيرنوبيل فحسب ، بل كذبت السلطات أيضًا
على الناس حولها ، الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم ، أنا
أحد الأطفال الذين ساروا
بعد أربعة أيام من المظاهرة
لأنه لم يتم إخبار أحد في الواقع أن
الأطفال أجبروا على الخروج
حتى  تتأثر وقد أمضينا
سنوات عديدة مع شركائنا الأوروبيين
والأمريكيين في تغطيتها
وحماية الموقع والقيام
بهذا الحبس الجديد بحيث لا يمثل
تهديدًا لأي شخص بعد الآن ، وخاصةً
كنا حريصين جدًا على عدم تعكير صفو
الأرض و  العمل بعناية حيث
كان ذلك ممكنًا فقط ، وهذا يظهر فقط
الاحترام القليل للحياة الذي
يظهره الروس في كل مكان في أوكرانيا
حتى لجنودهم ، أعني كيف
أنني لا أعرف حتى كيف أقول مدى
قسوة أو غباء أو عليك أن  يجب أن
تقول لجنودك أن يحفروا
في مكان الإشعاع حيث علموا
أنه ليس
مسموحًا بالقيام بذلك ، فقد كان يعتقد منذ فترة طويلة أن
فلاديمير بوتين يريد ذلك الممر من
دونيتسك  على طول الطريق آه
من دونباس وصولاً إلى
شبه جزيرة القرم وربما حولها حتى أوديسا ،
هل تعتقد أن أوكرانيا ستسمح
بذلك ، يمكن أن يصبح ذلك نقطة مساومة
إذا كانت هناك محادثات
أه لا لا أعتقد أن أوكرانيا ستسمح
لي بذلك  لا أعتقد أنني لا أعتقد أن أي
سياسي في وضع يسمح
له بإتخاذ قرار بقطع جزء من
الأمة ذات السيادة وإعطائها
لبوتين لمجرد أه من
أه لأن بوتين يريد ذلك أه يعني
لا أعتقد أن هذا غير قانوني أه في الواقع
من أي منظور قانوني أوكراني أو دولي
لا أعتقد أن
الشعب الأوكراني شعب أوكراني
يقاوم ويقاتل من أجل
حريتهم أه وأم لذا لا أعتقد أن
هذا أه  الشيء الذي
يجب على أي دولة فعله هو الرد على
العدوان بالقول حسنًا ، نحن هنا
لنأخذ ثلث البلد ،
خذها كما تعلم ، لأن أه في هذه الحالة
سيتقدم بوتين ، أعني أنه
ليس كما يريد.  دونباس أه إنه
يريد أوكرانيا  وأه إذا سمحنا له
بسهولة أن يأخذ جزءًا من البلاد
فإنه سيتقدم أكثر